hey everyone this is the quick video  from the road we are in ann arbor  michigan right now i'm doing some  interviews for my book and i just wanted  to send a quick shout out to Lucy Lucy  is one of our super loyal youtube  viewers yes they see him coming every  day tons of comments and Lucy I was in  the hospital recently she is multiple  sclerosis and she was in the hospital  bed watching the videos and talking  about how much the readers are helping  her recover and she believes she's gonna  beat em s and so just want to give a  shout-out and I hope you guys can all  give a warm believe nation get well soon  to Lucy and hope you I hope you beat  this thing we're with you know get well  soon get well soon leave a comment for  Lucy and that will see you soon and  believe believe believe